ضيفنا حذر منذ سنوات في بحث علمي من ان
منطقه شمال افريقيا ستكون عرضه لكوارث
الساحليه وفي اعقاب ما حدث في ليبيا قال
ان درنا ليست الاسوا لكنها مجرد انذار بما
هو اسوا درنا انت قلت بانها بدايه الاسوا
وليست الاسوا رى هنا معدلات سقوط الامطار
في العاصفه التي اتت على منطقه دا هرنا
وهي هنا ونلاحظ ان العاصفه لم تدخل في
العمق اذا كل المياه
التي تجمعت في السدود تدع تجمعت في السدود
السفليه الاثنين اللي هم اللي اخر قبل
المدينه وهم دول السدول السدين اللي
انهاروا لو كان لو كان لو كان للعاصفه ان
تدخل اكثر وتحطم
السد الثالث لكانت الماساه اكبر لذلك هي
ليست الاسوا لذلك ما نراه ما نراه هو هو
سوء استعداد منا ولكن ليس هو التغير كان
يمكن تداركه بالفعل الخريطه الثانيه نبقى
دائما مع موضوع درنا وهذا هنا بيوضح كميه
الاتربه التي تحركت من الداخل في هذه
الصوره بالقمر الصناعي
وبالاحرى التي تحركت من الداخل الى الشريط
الساح هو في الساحل وبنشوف كل هذه الاتر
والهين اللي تحرك الى
الشريط هنا في المنطقه الساحليه وكانه تم
ردم هذه الشواطئ هذا ما تحول قوله كانه تم
ردم جزء كبير من المدينه بالكامل ما
خطورته البيئيه الان الخطوره البيئيه الان
ان هو هي اعاده الاعمار كيف ستتم اعاده
الاعمار
بازاله ملايين الامتار المكعبه من الطين
وكيف سيتم بناء فوق
هذه التكوينات الجديده هو امر مش سهل هذه
الخريطه باللون الاحمر هي الاتربه اللي
وصلت الى مدينه دهرنا وبنشوف ان الاتربه
دي ليست فقط من احواز المدينه ولكنها من
مناطق
عميقه داخل الشريط الساحلي ونرى هنا
المدينه دهرنا في هذا المثلث
وكميه ال
الهين الذي يغطي كل المدينه
[موسيقى]
بالكامل